voici le lapin de pâques bah oui on a
compris on n'est pas idiot quoi oui et
grâce au lapin on reçoit quand même deux
semaines de vacances ces vacances de
pâques dans votre cinéma préféré le
meilleur espion et monde face à filtrer
ton nouveau titre r je crois que gamma
voit clair dans mon jeu kaputt bp comme
un as fait pour passer devant le tarn je
n'ai jamais connu une telle humiliation
baby bosse maintenant au cinéma
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
meyer respirons vaches s'infiltrer dans
la lutte entre les bébés et les chiots
qu'est-ce que tu te regardes les enfants
ont fini par certains boss meilleur
respire on va s'infiltrer dans la lutte
entre les bébés et les chiots regarde
les enfants ont fini par certains baby
boss
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]